[Musique]
dans le reste de l'actualité le Medef
Yvelines inauguré hier soir ses nouveaux
locaux à Montigny-le-Bretonneux près
d'une centaine de chefs d'entreprises
étaient présents sur place pour
découvrir ce lieu auparavant implanté à
Versailles Grand open space salle de
réunion et salon pour recevoir les
adhérents ces bureaux de 155 mètres
carrés ont été choisis pour avoir
davantage d'espace et être au cœur de
l'activité économique 50e
un événement solidaire ce mercredi 7
septembre l'association Lyon club Vélizy
Phoenix organisé une collecte de
fournitures scolaires dans le centre
Westfield Vélizy 2 objectifs aider les
familles en difficulté à s'équiper pour
la rentrée les dons seront ensuite
reversés à des écoles ukrainiennes ou
sénégalaises en France les récoltes
seront notamment distribuées au resto du
coeur pour épauler les familles
yvelinoise dans le besoin nous avons
besoin d'à peu près tout ce qui se fait
en fournitures scolaires de du
taille-crayon
jusqu'au cartable en passant par les
cahiers les
gommes les stylos les feutres les
ardoises Vileda recharger son smartphone
en pédalant c'est le concept original
proposé depuis quelques jours à
Magny-les-Hameaux sur la plaine de
Chevincourt deux bandes de recherche
permettent aux utilisateurs d'éviter la
panne de batterie à la seule force des
jambes grâce à une application gratuite
il est possible de voir la charge en
temps réel de quoi motiver certains à se
remettre au sport